hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
while the breach on capitol hill is at
the center of president trump's second
impeachment trial aaron hawley wife of
gop senator josh hawley
is sharing details about protesters that
gathered outside their virginia home
in early january as a lawyer and an
associate professor of law at the
university of missouri
she weighs in on the division in the
country and responds to backlash over
her husband objecting to affirm
president biden's election victory
teachers unions and school boards
continue to clash over how to safely
return
to in-person learning amid the
coronavirus pandemic
randy weingarten president of the
american federation of teachers
discusses reopening debates
and the challenge is to flesh out
president biden's push to reopen schools
within his first 100 days in office
plus commentary from guy benson host of
the guy benson show
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm steve ducey i'm kennedy i'm bill
hemmer and this
is the fox news rundown
[Music]
friday february 12 2021
i'm grinnell scott reaction to our
political discourse can often bring
protests
and fear to a family's doorstep aaron
hawley
wife of republican missouri senator josh
hawley talks about
her experience i think i had two initial
thoughts you know one um you know can i
protect abigail
and two oh my goodness i am so glad
my two boys are not here as they would
be absolutely terrified
i'm lisa brady how to reopen schools
can new cdc guidance help cool
a heated debate i worry about
this recklessness about trying to pit
educators versus kids and i'm guy benson
i've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
lawmakers in the united states congress
make many decisions that affect
americans some that people like and
some they don't the reaction to those
very decisions have evolved from
simple spirited debate to personal
attacks and
in your face protests that many will
tell you have contributed to the
breakdown of our political
and civil discourse families of
lawmakers are not immune
often seeing the anger they have little
direct involvement with
up close on january 4th two days before
the violence at the capitol that is now
at the center of former president
trump's
second impeachment trial protesters
gathered outside the virginia home
of senator josh hawley and his family
the missouri republicans decision to
object
to affirm joe biden's election victory
would later get him dropped
from a major publisher but that night
brought angry demonstrators
literally to his front door at first was
just a little bit of disbelief
aaron hawley is a lawyer professor and
the wife
of missouri republican senator josh
hawley i
was downstairs watching tv my husband
and two boys were at home in missouri so
i was home alone
with our then seven week old daughter
abigail and we were watching a hallmark
show
so just having a good girls evening
when we heard shouts outside
i came upstairs and saw about 15 to 20
protesters
standing outside they were shouting into
bull horns
i you know of course had no idea who
they were
or what precisely they wanted and again
was home alone with abigail and i think
as
as any parent as any mom
is worried about you just want to be
able to protect your child
so i think i had two initial thoughts
you know one um you know can i protect
abigail
um and two oh my goodness i am so glad
my two boys are not here uh as they
would be absolutely terrified
you dealt with it and and you confronted
these folks you
you went out and said look you know we
have
i have family here there are neighbors
around here
please take this somewhere else or or
something like that and and and they
continued
um and and i guess the the the
anxiety began to heighten at that point
yes i i asked the protesters to leave i
told them that we had a new baby
and that we also had neighbors um and
you know this is
obviously not an appropriate place to
have a protest late at night
um when other families are trying to go
around about
their evening business as as well as our
own family
um and yes when they didn't leave that
they just sort of heightened heighten
the situation i went back downstairs
with abby and then heard shouting up
close
and pounding and i came upstairs and
there were at least three men
on my front porch we've got you know
ordinary door with some side windows
and they basically took up the whole
whole front of my porch
and were shouting into full horns and at
that point
um i started to get get a little nervous
as anyone would and it's just it's a
real invasion
of the safety of your home to have
people on your
porch shouting in bull horns people you
don't know who
they are what their specific intent is
whether they're dangerous and again this
is all at night
when they're sure or nearly sure that a
family will be home
which is just completely inappropriate
and you talked about the police response
and
and they did come and they did try to
get these folks to disperse but
even in the time that it took them to
respond which was
a relatively short amount of time when
you're in the middle of it when you're
in the throes of it it seems like
forever
absolutely and if you just think about
it you know there's glass outside of a
lot of
doors and you break the glass and you
turn the knob
and it wouldn't take long for someone to
get into most homes
so you're thinking all of that when
you're there by yourself
and i'm grateful for their response and
it's my understanding that they informed
the protesters that they were violating
several different laws um and they
eventually uh
did disperse uh but again while while
you're
uh you know waiting uh a place to come
that there's a lot that can happen
um in that time frame and even if
nothing happens
uh i i again cannot express how grateful
i am that our two small boys
were not home they are six years old and
eight years old
and one in particular um is already
afraid of the dark you know much like
any
any child of that age is often uh afraid
of the dark and afraid of someone
getting in
um and the idea that he would have seen
these people out in the dark
shouting with bullhorns or the idea that
he would have heard them
up on the porch shouting into our house
i am
so thankful that he wasn't here for that
and the idea that he might experience
that someday
really just breaks my heart as a mom
because it's our responsibility
to protect our children to the best of
our ability um
so so it's just my hope and prayer that
he does not experience
anything like that well i have you here
and
and i know this is uh what you recounted
was january 4th i i have to ask you
about two days later
and and what happened at the u.s capitol
and i'm sure you like
me like me like many of us watched that
day
as as people stormed the capital and
overran security and i'm sure your phone
was working overtime that day
at least trying to get in touch with
your husband to make sure he was
okay what were you feeling that day
again just a sense of disbelief
um and really fear uh for my husband um
it's one thing when when you're there
and possibly can do something about it
but when you're just hearing about it
and watching it um
it really i have no sense of control and
so just was just praying for my
husband's safety for his colleagues
safety um and as you said just a
tragic and terrible event and
we are thankful as a family that
my husband was safe and you know
feel very deeply for the loss that was
sustained that day
you're aware a lot of people uh and and
many of them are democrats many of them
people who have followed the political
process have
have warranted or not pointed fingers
at your husband uh alleging that in some
way on that day
he somehow encouraged
the writers uh on january 6th
if you could not have an argument but a
conversation with somebody who perhaps
stood in that corner
what would you what would you talk to
them about what would you say
and perhaps to change their mind
well i love what you say about having a
conversation
and i would tell them first of all that
josh is a good man
he has a good heart he loves his boys
he's a good husband
and i would urge them to get to know him
as our neighbors have
who have been so generous with their
support notwithstanding
many who have contrary political views
so i would urge them to get to know him
and
if they did so they would realize the
notion that he encouraged
any sort of violence is absolutely
ridiculous
senator hawley of course knee deep in
this senate impeachment trial as a jury
member
some have speculated as to how he'll
vote when this ultimately comes to the
point where he has to vote
only he knows that for sure you may have
some idea but only he knows that for
sure
but uh and i know of no other way to
really ask this but to ask this point
blank
that day on january 6.
among all the members of congress who
were on capitol hill at that time and
your husband was on
one of them his safety was at risk
should the rhetoric of the former
president donald trump
and others who spoke at the rally
earlier that day be held accountable
for that and i asked that not i asked
that of you not as someone who is part
of
or who knows the political process but
as a wife
who for some time that day wasn't sure
how this was going to play out
uh well as you said as a wife as a
spouse it is terrifying
uh when those you love are under threat
in any way including from serious
threats
to their safety as happened on january
6th
and i think it's absolutely right and
proper that those individuals who breach
the
boundaries of the capital be prosecuted
to the full extent
of the law i am not as familiar
with the president's rhetoric so i
cannot speak to that
but i am very much in favor
of those who broke the law being
prosecuted
so we live in a society who's built on
the idea
that we have this democratic process
that's representative
and to break in to the representative's
house
is really a threat to all of us so if
people should and are being prosecuted
i recently had a conversation with
former congressman trey gowdy and i
asked him about what we can do to
perhaps repair our political rhetoric i
will ask you the same
question but in a bit of a different
vein if
if you could make a suggestion as to how
we can
uh repair our political rhetoric
but i'll add in the fact that not it's
not always
the politician that suffers the slings
and arrows in this era of social media
and the internet
people can find their families and and
terrorize them as well as you have
experience how do we
how do we get past that how do we solve
this i think we realize
uh that we're all people and we're all
americans
and for the most part people have good
intentions
as you mentioned it's often the family
these days it gets
caught in the crosshairs my
sister-in-law her office had a bomb
threat
and we've had all sorts of threats to
our families safety
on social media i changed my phone
number i shut down
instagram instagram's supposed to be the
happy social media um but but not so
much
um and so i think that all of these
actions are just really damaging to the
fabric of our democracy
because they don't engage people with
people um and we
need people who are willing to stand up
for what they believe in regardless
of the blowback on social media or on
twitter
and i think my husband is one of those
people
and we need a people who are willing to
look one and other in the eye
um and say what it is as you might in
law school you can have a candid debate
about these sorts of issues uh rather
than resorting to social media
and the anonymity that that sort of
platform brings
so really talking to people getting to
know where they're coming from
all of these things are are really
elementary but in today's
sort of click uh first and and
send your tweet first uh culture we're
really missing out on just that human
element
and the fact that most people really do
mean well
aaron hawley we are glad you are safe
and i do want to thank you for your
your candor your honesty and your time
to talk about this issue thank you so
much for joining us
thank you so much for having me
[Music]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
school districts around the country are
about to have more information
on what it would take to get kids and
teachers back into classrooms
the president wants schools to open
safely and in accord with science
white house spokeswoman jensaki has been
deferring questions on specifics
to the cdc ahead of the new guidelines
they're releasing
but reporters have tried to drill down
on the president's goal of having
most k-8 schools reopen in his first 100
days
the majority of schools so more than 50
percent
open by day 100 of his presidency and
that means
some teaching in classrooms so at least
one day a week hopefully it's more
skeptics say the president just doesn't
want to take on the teachers unions part
of his core
support florida republican senator marco
rubio telling fox news they've just
redefined what opening schools means
they defined it as something that's
virtually already happening so they can
claim they did it
in the meantime there's been a tug of
war in some districts over reopening
plans
leading to lawsuits and public feuds
when chicago
finally reached a tentative deal with
its teachers union recently
mayor lori lightfoot had kind words for
the teachers
you have been champions all while
fighting through this roller coaster
of your own personal emotions and
dealing with your
personal health and your family
i understand that and i want to thank
you but she said parents and students
had told her
they felt held hostage and while
thousands of union members voted for the
deal
thousands also voted against it but if
the basics of pandemic safety are known
masks social distancing testing and
tracing
why aren't more schools already back to
in-person learning
there's several issues one is that
you know you got about thirteen thousand
districts that are doing thirteen
thousand things
randy weingarten is president of the
american federation of teachers
which put out its own blueprint for a
gradual reopening
last april the districts that have not
you know have not reopened for in-person
learning
many of them have not had the money to
make the ventilation changes
um have not had the money to purchase
the ppe
did not have the money for the
sanitation
and the hygiene and the cleaning
and a lot of them got that kind of money
this um
in the november into this december
package
so that was a really good first step
the second is the lack
of putting in these mitigation
strategies
with fidelity that people would trust
and so
what you're seeing right now in the
districts
that have just you know had new
agreements in the last few days
it's there are now parent and teacher
committees
that are making sure that the the
mitigation strategies are really put
into effect
um and that they are there
to provide safety for students and for
staff
the last issue is we got to make sure
that people have the um
you know the vaccine availability you
know teachers should be part of the
priority
for vaccines there's that priority
should be aligned with
in-school learning and some states are
doing that and some are not i applaud
washington d.c for really trying
to make educator vaccinations a priority
in reopening schools
i applaud west virginia for doing that
but then
basically um florida refused to do that
florida basically said that uh no
essential worker
um was essential enough to be um
in the head of the line in terms of
vaccine prioritization
let's talk about the president's goal
for a minute
because do you feel like he kind of
backed himself into a corner
by saying that most k-8 schools should
be reopened in the first hundred days
and now the white house has kind of had
to backtrack when pressed on it and say
well even one day of in person learning
a per week would count toward you know
meeting that goal i mean there's kind of
yeah go ahead i don't see the white
house as backtracking on this i think
i think what's happened is we live in a
society where
donald trump never let the scientists
speak fulsomely so most people didn't
even know what was in the original cdc
guidelines
which basically said that to reopen
school safely
you had to have a series of mitigation
strategies that included
masking and physical distancing
if you actually understand physical
distancing nothing that jensaki said
this week would surprise you because
you know it means that you have to have
enough space
and enough clustering of kids um
to to reopen safely to so that there's
enough
um space in between people and and so
we thought last school year as the
school year started
that would essentially mean you need
about 20 or 30 percent
more space in schools and if you don't
have that
that's going to mean much more of a
hybrid
and i think that's what gen sayakasaki
was saying so it's
literally taking these scientific
guidelines
and making it real for people and that's
why you have so many school districts
that are doing hybrid
because that's the number of kids that
they can
um have in school given the space
and the number of teachers they have now
federal health officials
have said that based on the science it's
not
necessary to have all of the teachers
vaccinated before you have in-person
learning
resuming but that has been
an issue that's been under debate in
some of the districts as they tried to
reach
agreements and in san francisco where
they did reach an agreement
after the city sued the school district
the mayor london breed is now raising
doubts about whether they can go
forward with reopening right at this
time because she's saying
you know it does call for all teachers
to be vaccinated but they have a vaccine
supply issue so the bottom line is
you can't have it both ways we can't
actually say that essential workers are
essential
and we're trying to vaccinate them first
because their work is essential and then
say
but we really didn't mean it so so yes
vaccinations are not a prerequisite it's
not a prerequisite that every single
school teacher
be vaccinated before you reopen
in-person learning
but the cdc has made
teachers just like healthcare workers
priorities
and so that means in a city a mayor has
to actually
put aside some of the vaccines that amer
gets
for the city to do that and what you
know the
the san francisco mayor is saying in
that position in right now
is that she doesn't want to do what
clearly
the mayor in d.c just did what the
west virginia governor just did so it's
not that
what vaccines do is that they create
another
layer of protection and i'm really glad
that we're seeing educators clamor for
the vaccines
i thought we'd have much more of a
problem in terms of vaccine
hesitancy and we have some of that but
i'm really glad to see
educators seeing that vaccines can
provide
another layer so is it a prerequisite
that every teacher get
vaccinated before you reopen public
schools in person
no but should we be aligning
vaccine prioritization and vaccine
availability within school learning
of course i wanted to dig in a little
too on the give and take that happened
in chicago before they reached their
tentative agreement where the mayor
basically said
look the schools are safe and the union
basically said
no they're not they're not safe enough
and there's been this public
perception around that or at least it
seemed like it at times
that the union was being portrayed as
kind of the bad guy in this fight are
you
worried about that perception going
forward
i worry about this um
recklessness about trying to pick
educators versus kids and unfortunately
the mayor
in um in chicago did this there
is a um there there
there is a healthy skepticism in
districts that have had austerity heaped
upon them that things that are going to
be promised
are not delivered and so for the mayor
to be stand up and say
trust me this is going to happen when we
have years and years of austerity and
disinvestment in chicago
people didn't trust it they said let's
actually make sure we have this
in writing and that it's enforceable and
the mayor didn't want to do that
and so ultimately god they got to a
point where they did that
um but it was really unfortunate because
it was only
after there was a strike vote that the
mayor took these negotiations seriously
if the mayor took those negotiations
seriously weeks beforehand
it would never have gotten to a strike
vote and so
ultimately look at what happened in new
york city in new york city we negotiated
a whole set of safety protocols that
would make schools safe
for reopening of in-school learning and
frankly
around the country parents get that if
teachers believe that it's safe
then it's going to be safe for their
kids do we know that in school learning
is really important
yes we're school teachers we would have
told you before covet
that remote education wasn't so great
but we
need to make sure that it's safe and
and part of why we have been negotiating
and and putting out plans since last
april
is because we knew that it was really
important to have in-school learning for
kids
to develop relationships develop
resilience but we also know
for our kids for our parents and for
ourselves
we need to be safe randy weingarten
president of the american federation of
teachers
thank you very much for your time thank
you so much really appreciate it
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
the coronavirus pandemic has meant doing
without a lot of things many of us took
for granted
one of the simplest things on that list
a hug
it's been especially difficult for
people with loved ones in nursing homes
or long-term care facilities
so our good news this week comes from
colorado where an assisted living center
in suburban denver came up with a way to
make it possible for family members to
safely hug their relatives who stay
there
juniper village set up a hug tent
outside the facility where all of the
residents and staff have been vaccinated
it's made of a lot of construction grade
plastic sheeting
complete with plastic sleeves the
associated press reports that
similar tents have popped up around the
country and at places like brazil and
england where some people call them
cuddle curtains
amanda meyer is the project coordinator
for the non-profit health care
organization true community care
and said she her husband and some
volunteers built the hug
tent around a standard eight by eight
foot pop-up
frame and attached the construction
grade plastic with glue and velcro
the plastic arm sleeves built into the
tent are attached with
embroidery hoops since the beginning of
november
she's helped set up four of those hugged
tents in colorado
and said the feedback has been positive
she says initially it's kind of weird to
be hugging through plastic
but the benefits are clear and that you
can see a sort of relief
in their bodies and faces when they
finally get to have physical contact
hugs just one more thing we won't take
for granted
tanya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy benson
what's on your mind as tens of millions
of americans are now vaccinated against
coronavirus some people are ringing
their hands saying that even after
people get vaccinated
the risk isn't zero and therefore we
should all curtail
talk about getting back to normal
anytime soon the white house press
secretary added from the podium last
week that even after vaccinations people
are going to have to stick to a program
of social distancing and mask wearing i
fear that this sort of negativity
may persuade people who are on the fence
not to get vaccines
if they feel like the goal posts are
ever shifting but here's the reality the
new york times recently reported quote
all five vaccines with public results
have
eliminated covid19 deaths they have also
drastically reduced hospitalizations end
quote we should be responsible and
careful
but we shouldn't needlessly discourage
people either the proven promise of
these vaccines is something to celebrate
not downplay or frame is not good enough
this is guy benson host of the guy
benson show
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast
former federal prosecutor and four-term
u.s congressman from south carolina
brings you a one-of-a-kind podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes